i have a surprise and it is possibly the
best thing to potentially ever happen to
anyone anywhere in the history of the
universe ladies and gentlemen the world
famous lil sebastian what yes
i never thought i'd get to meet him it's
really him well done leslie well done
lil sebastian made his debut at the last
harvest festival in 1987 and he was an
instant phenomenon for the next few
years sebastian was the number one boy's
name in pawnee
and the number three girl's name so what
am i missing what's the deal with this
pony he's not a pony van he's a mini
horse there's a big difference well then
why is he so famous does he do something
what does he do son this horse has an
honorary degree from notre dame we all
need to be very careful okay remember
this little guy's 25 now and he has
cataracts in both eyes he has severe
arthritis jerry's gonna look after him
yes i am we are both on the same
diabetes medication are you my glucotrol
buddy are you
isn't it amazing
yeah i just got to be honest i don't
know what the big deal is
get out
i've been staring at this board for days
i'm so close to putting it together
there's got to be something we missed
let's go over this again
the video shows that the pie came from a
high angle
so it would have hit your face
like this
don't close your eyes
no no it actually was from up higher
is that about right
yeah good
clean yourself up let's do this again
hey ann what happened i just saw you a
few hours ago and you were fine not like
damn you're fine but fine health-wise
my body has no fat to protect itself
from disease things happen very quickly
listen to me it's very important that
you replenish my body with electrolytes
after every involuntary loss of bodily
fluids oh boy my body tends to lose a
lot
of fluids
when it's sick
my brain is on fire i'm dying
well you definitely have the flu
oh my god
the microchip has been compromised
i vomited somewhere in this room
i don't remember where though
wait you might want to check that drawer
stop
pooping
you don't even know one thing i didn't
even say what they're gonna do she asked
me the whole thing and i didn't even do
it once i'm like an elephant okay if i
walk into a room it's like okay he's in
there
turn this music down
[Music]
tom's in the trunk jerry's on the roof
all right where to first
your mother's butt
[Laughter]
i'm so alone
if even one of you thinks about dry
heaven in my car you're all walking home
you're okay your eyes are glassy oh my
god oh my is she she's sick are you sick
no yeah she's sick
that's why i'm wearing this and misting
myself with hand sanitizer
i'm not sick i just have allergies okay
i took a claritin and i threw that up so
i took another one i threw that up and
then i took a third and it stayed down
i'm getting better all right you're
burning up you're burning up what i have
to get out of here i have 2.8 body fat
my body's like a microchip a grain of
sand could destroy it
my body's a microchip
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets commerce if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the harvest
festival is gonna be over before it
began i cannot go home okay then who is
your doctor
ann's my doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world
come on
oh girl now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
i'm sorry but the ben wyatt that i know
i just don't think he'd be happy he's
sitting here
faffing around i'm not
faffing around i've sunk myself into my
hobbies here
i'll show you my claymation project okay
now i've been working pretty hard on
this and
i think it's really good so just hang on
to your hat okay okay here goes
oh great
[Music]
did you pause it no i
hang on
oh my god
that's the whole thing
that's three weeks of work you're gonna
be okay
no no no no i'm not you see in my head i
thought that was really really cool
i i i emailed leslie two days ago and i
compared it to avatar chris and how can
it not be longer
hey bro
listen i was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b25
mitchell panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and i went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey ron
swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are
yeah
okay um there are these things called
cookies where like if you go to a site
and buy something it'll remember you and
then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to google
earth and type in your address
if i thought you were serious i'd be
offended bird but i know that we're
buddies i know you wouldn't do that to
me but no this is a birthmark perd okay
this is the little scar i got when i was
nine and i fell off my bike so no i'm
not perfect
i can't look away it's um it's amazing
okay we're all right no here's the best
part okay uh that's all the time we have
here on you heard i'm heard happily
channel four more like turd crapley
[Applause]
so while they repaint the lines in the
parking lot we're asking everyone to do
street parking i'm not street parking my
mercedes well everyone is i'm doing it
cause nobody wants to steal a saturn
all right uh moving on to recycling
you okay ron
just a little tooth pain i'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist ron i
don't like dentists
just a second
hey no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
oh my god i'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling
dentist pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see tom faint
[Laughter]
[Applause]
tom
i couldn't afford enough premium carpet
to get us to the stage i mean it was a
short walk but it was pretty luxurious
right
okay
everybody smile away
[Music]
i'm leaning on my arm andy
[Music]
yeah
hey
i'm holding the dog he's peeing he's now
peeing and putting him down no ronnie
only has three legs
[Music]
run
there's no scares how do i get to the
stage
[Music]
hey
you